mieux pour nos collègues qui sont c'est
pas le mot magique mais parce que j'ai
goûté tous les maux de leur part donc
que je salue mais c'est vrai que sur la
pilule contraceptive délivrés sans
ordonnance
il ya eu des consignes ordinale de
données pour qu'elle se soit fait
alors il ya quelques confrères qui s'y
sont refusées mais la grande majorité
des officines répondent aujourd'hui à
ceux de ce besoin
on est bien d'accord là dessus donc il
n'y a pas de barrage en tout cas delà de
la profession au contraire les officines
ont bien joué le jeu
voilà mais s'il faut le rappeler s'il
faut le modifier a même présenté par la
loi faisons le ayant le courage sur un
défaut si préconisations matière de
santé ayant le courage de dire parce que
ça c'est c'est un quart de trois mots
dans le code de santé publique 1 c
pardon d'être intervenue voilà c'est
toujours intéressant et un total à ce
que vous allez présenter et